after a two-year pause due to covet 19
rock and roll las vegas running series
is back it all kicks off today in
downtown las vegas that is where we find
our kevin martin joining us live from
the starting line of the 5k hey there
kevin
well hey sasha at the start line here in
downtown las vegas for the 5k you can
see behind me there's a steady stream of
runners still going and we are seeing so
many about 30 thousand participants will
take part in this two-day event and
nearly 7 000 runners here participating
in the 5k now this is just one of 14
cities that will host a rock and roll
running series event but vegas is
considered the grand daddy of them all
there's nothing like it this is the
super bowl of running events okay from
the music to the characters to the
community vegas is our super bowl so
because of what we're able to do here
shutting down the boulevard at night
we've completely taken what would
normally be a wonderful race experience
and just elevated
it just to give you an idea of how fast
some of these guys are going we're
standing at the two mile mark it is
approximately 5 11. this race started at
5 p.m
some of these guys are moving this is
insane to watch this there goes a girl
right there absolutely incredible and on
the other side we still have a stream of
runners
so much fun here like you said this is
the super bowl of the rock and roll and
it's so much fun here seven thousand
runners will be participating here today
and of course coming up at six we'll be
live at the finish line to talk to some
of these guys who finish the 5k
reporting live in downtown las vegas
kevin martin live local now
kevin looks like fun down there and hey
beware there will be several road
closures tomorrow and sunday along that
race route as you could tell there areas
impacted include the strip and downtown
there will also be some ramp closures on
the i-15 you can find more information
and maps on our website eight newsnow
dot com